mesdames et messieurs après une première
table ronde de ce matin consacrée au
secteur dit du Caire nous poursuivons
nos travaux sectoriels consacrés au
secteur d'activité les plus féminisées
au sein desquels les risques
professionnels sont souvent
sous-estimées et les politiques de
prévention dédiées aux femmes
insuffisamment développé notre second
tableau ronde de la matinée porte sur
les métiers de la grande distribution
d'une part et ceux du nettoyage d'autre
part de la propreté souvent utilisée je
rappelle que quatre rapporteurs ont été
désignés par notre délégation pour
étudier la thématique de la santé des
femmes au travail il s'agit de Laurence
Cohen Laurence Rossignol Marie-Pierre
Richer et Annick Jacquemet qui sont avec
nous ce matin s'agissant de la grande
distribution les femmes représentent 60%
des employés elles occupent plus de
trois quarts des postes de caissiers et
de donc on pourrait presque dire de
caissières et 40% d'entre elles sont
atteintes partiels les caissières et
employés de libre-services sont
régulièrement exposé au risque de
troubles musculo-squelettiques les TMS
s'agissant des métiers du nettoyage 8
emplois sur 10 sont occupés par des
femmes le plus souvent
âgées de plus de 50 ans sans diplôme et
d'origine étrangère ces métiers sont
très exposés au risque physique 71% des
salariés de la propreté sont exposés au
travail répétitif 61% au risque
chimiques et 52% aux postures pénibles
en plus des TMS des agents de propreté
sont donc soumis à un important risque
chimique dû à la composition de produits
utilisés ainsi qu'un rythme de travail
intense et plus souvent fragmenté
le secteur de la propreté est également
le plus grand employeur de travailleurs
à temps partiel puisque dans les métiers
de nettoyage plus de la moitié des
postes principaux sont occupés à temps
partiel quels sont les obstacles à
l'identification des facteurs de risque
et à la reconnaissance des maladies
professionnelles dans ces secteurs
particulièrement féminisés comment
réussir à mettre en place des actions de
prévention efficaces dans ces secteurs
pour affranchir approfondir pardon ces
différents sujets nous accueillons ce
matin Guillaume boulanger responsable de
l'unité qualité de vie des milieux de
vie et du travail et santé des
populations chez santé publique France
François-Xavier déveterres professeur
des universités au centre lillois
d'études et de recherche sociologique et
économiques co-auteur de l'ouvrage 2
millions de travailleurs et des
poussières l'avenir des emplois du
nettoyage dans une dans une société
juste parue en 2022
et anitébo money sociologue de la santé
directrice honoraire de recherche à
l'INSERM accompagné de Marie-Christine
Liman ancienne infirmière du travail
toute de membres du groupement d'intera
scientifiques pour sur les cancers
d'origine professionnelle du Vaucluse le
giscope 84 Université d'Avignon donc je
laisse sans plus tarder la parole à
notre première intervenant Guillaume
boulanger qui représente santé publique
France cette agence nationale de santé
publique a participé à une étude de
surveillance épidémiologique sur les
maladies à caractère professionnel chez
les salariés de la grande distribution
alimentaire et publiera dans quelques
semaines un rapport sur les maladies
professionnelles avec des données
genrées qui pourront évidemment nourrir
nos travaux ici à la délégation à vous
monsieur
très bien écoutez je vais être attentif
autant et respecter les 10 minutes qui
nous sont alloués donc je voulais vous
remercier
et j'ai le plaisir de pouvoir partager
avec vous ces résultats concernant la
grande distribution alimentaire et donc
vous remercier pour cette invitation
alors j'ai prévu quelques diapositives
peut-être vous vous rappeler où vous
présenter ce qu'on appelle une maladie
professionnelle c'est important pour
bien comprendre la suite des résultats
le terme de maladies professionnelles
est défini par la loi et correspond aux
conséquences directes de l'exposition
d'un travailleur merci
à un risque ou résulte des conditions
dans lesquelles il exerce son activité
professionnelle alors on entend souvent
parler des données de l'assurance
maladie les accidents du travail les
maladies professionnelles qu'on appelle
les maladies professionnelles
indemnisées et qu'il faut l'objet de
tableau de maladie ou parfois lorsque
les conditions ne sont pas suffisantes
ou qu'il n'y a pas de tableau il y a un
système de complémentaire de
reconnaissance donc ça c'est des données
qui sont assez visibles sur la
réparation par les régimes de sécurité
sociale donc j'ai mentionné la CNAM mais
aussi par exemple la MSA pour le monde
agricole
ça c'est souvent la face immergée de
l'iceberg et si on considère toutes les
maladies professionnelles il y a des
maladies qui sont pas reconnues parce
qu'il n'y a pas de tableau de maladie
professionnelle ou que elles font pas
l'objet d'une demande par le salarié de
reconnaissance et ça ça représente
finalement on verra par la suite un
j'allais dire un corpus important de
maladies professionnelles alors c'est là
c'est justement l'objectif de notre
programme de travail à santé publique
France c'est de surveiller et de rendre
visible ces maladies plus globalement à
caractère professionnel donc depuis 2003
on a mis un programme en place sur la
surveillance de ces maladies à caractère
professionnel
alors la maladie de la notion de maladie
à caractère professionnel a été défini
avec la mise en place du premier tableau
donc c'est ancien ça date de 1919 et
normalement tout médecin et notamment
les médecins du travail doivent déclarer
une maladie qui présente à son avis
d'après son expertise un caractère
professionnel donc ça c'est prévu par le
code de la sécurité sociale il n'y avait
pas de de décret d'application ou de
modalités pour j'allais dire organiser
ce signalement et donc le code de la
santé publique à donner la charge à
santé publique France depuis 2003 en
partenariat avec l'inspection médicale
du travail et les observatoires
régionaux de santé de donc monter ce
système de centralisation des données
concernant les maladies à caractère
professionnel alors quels sont les
objectifs de ce programme c'est bien
d'estimer les prévalences de ces
maladies chez les salariés donc on
organise avec les médecins du travail de
quinzaine par an
pour justement faire remonter ce type de
pathologie c'est évidemment d'avoir un
suivi historique et c'est très important
de contribuer à l'estimation de la
sous-décration qui est très importante
pour les maladies professionnelles
indemnisables et puis de faire évoluer
les tableaux aussi et enfin la finalité
de santé publique c'est bien évidemment
d'orienter les politiques de prévention
en milieu professionnel
alors quelques chiffres sur la grande
distribution
pour rappel ou pour présentation donc la
grande distribution est définie par
l'ensemble des grandes moyennes et
petites surfaces de commerce de détails
et de bien et évidemment après dominance
alimentaire donc d'après les dernières
données que j'ai pu recenser un peu plus
de 40 44000 points de vente alimentaire
existe sur l'ensemble du territoire et
c'est un gros pourvoyeur d'emploi
puisque selon les chiffres entre 660 000
et 750 000 salariés travaillent dans ce
secteur là
comme vous l'avez souligné
ce secteur là est très féminisé plus de
60% environ 60% du secteur
donc comprend des femmes et puis c'est
un secteur plutôt jeune
avec une population qui par exemple
inclut un peu un peu moins de 40% de de
salariés qui ont moins de 35 ans ça a
été aussi également souligné ces
salariés et notamment ces femmes
salariées sont soumis à une
multi-exposition notamment des
contraintes biomécaniques physiques
répétition de mouvement manutention
organisationnel forte donc avec une
fragmentation des horaires du travail et
des contraintes aussi psychosociales
très fortes notamment en termes de
management mais surtout de contact avec
le public avec parfois des tensions
violences avec le public
en termes de maladies indemnisées c'est
un secteur qui est caractérisé par un
lourd fardeau donc une sinistralité
assez forte à la fois en accident du
travail mais aussi en termes de maladie
professionnelle et enfin il y a très peu
de données d'études épidémiologiques qui
s'intéressent en profondeur à ses
salariés du secteur
alors sur les résultats je vais me
concentrer uniquement sur les résultats
donc qui concerne les femmes salariés et
sans rentrer dans le détail évidemment
des résultats le point important qui me
semble à souligner c'est que les femmes
donc salariés de la grande distribution
présente des troubles musculus des
troubles pardon musculo-squelettiques
plus important de manière plus
importante que les autres secteurs et ce
pour toutes les localisations donc on va
pouvoir regarder le coup l'épaule le
rachis c'est-à-dire la colonne
vertébrale
les mains les mains les poignées etc à
chaque fois par rapport à toutes les
femmes salariées qui font partie de
notre programme de surveillance les
femmes qui travaillent dans la grande
distribution ont une prévalence un taux
plus élevé de signalement de troubles
musculo-squelettiques
sous la sur la souffrance psychique par
contre là c'est l'inverse on voit que il
y a un signalement moins important mais
on sait que il y a possiblement un biais
de déclaration en tout cas le point
important qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'il
y a une souffrance psychique qui est
déclarée dans ce secteur là et qu'elle
ait environ égale ou un peu inférieur
par rapport à l'ensemble des salariés
femmes de qui font l'objet d'une
surveillance dans le cadre de notre
programme
ce qui nous semblait aussi intéressant
c'est d'avoir un focus plus particulier
sur les caissières et ce qu'on appelle
les employés de libre-service donc c'est
tout ce qui c'est notamment les femmes
qui n'ont que sur le rayonnage donc qui
remplissent les rayons enfin voilà et
donc quand on regarde plus
particulièrement ce type de métier donc
de caissières ou d'employés de
libre-service là encore elles ont une
une tendance à avoir un risque plus
important de TMS par rapport aux autres
métiers de la grande distribution et par
rapport comme je le dis tout à l'heure
au secteur d'activité donc ça c'est vrai
à la fois pour les caissières et à la
fois pour les employés de libre-service
alors en termes de tendance c'est ça
aussi l'intérêt du programme c'est que
on voit qu'il y a une tendance à la
baisse significative de la prévalence
des TMS chez les salariés donc femmes de
la grande distribution alimentaire et
les hypothèses qu'on a qu'on a posé donc
que c'est une étude qui avait été
réalisée entre 2009 et 2016 c'est
notamment
l'implantation
de plus en plus forte de caisse dites
automatique à partir de 2007 qui a un
intérêt effectivement pour limiter les
TMS mais qui qui est
en tout cas montre par certaines études
qui a un report en fait là de pression
psychosociale puisque avant la caissière
était plutôt en relation avec le client
et maintenant elle est plutôt en
surveillance avec le client puisque vous
savez sur les caisses automatiques sur
les îlots n'assure pu ce rôle de
caissière mais plutôt de surveillance
également une évolution des conditions
de travail donc il y a une un effort
important qui a été fait en termes de
limitation du port de charge
et puis un certain nombre d'actions de
prévention qui ont été mises en place
notamment par la Caisse nationale
assurance maladie par contre pour la la
souffrance psychique ce qu'on voit c'est
clairement une augmentation à partir de
2010 et ce qu'on prévoit est-ce qu'il
faudrait qu'on fasse c'est une
actualisation pour voir si cette
tendance se prolonge après 2016
ma dernière diapositive concerne un peu
une ouverture pour alors aujourd'hui on
va discuter principalement la grande
distribution alimentaire et de
l'entretien alors on n'a pas fait de
travaux malheureusement sur l'entretien
mais j'ai bien noté ça pourrait faire
l'objet notamment dans notre programme
de travail d'une plaquette ou d'une
analyse particulière mais il me semble
intéressant aussi d'illustrer avec
d'autres travaux puisque à chaque fois
on fait des analyses genre et on avait
on a publié récemment une plaquette sur
des résultats qui concernent les femmes
aident à domicile et là encore une fois
on voit que les femmes aident à domicile
alors pour le coup de manière
caractéristique sont plus âgées plus
souvent à temps partiel et elles sont
exposées aussi à des contraintes
physiques très fortes ou biomécaniques
notamment de port de charge aussi on y
reviendra j'imagine par la suite une
exposition à des produits chimiques donc
notamment des agents nettoyants et puis
en contact aussi avec des agents
biologiques puisque souvent elles aident
un certain nombre de personnes qui sont
atteintes malades donc voilà
potentiellement à des agents infectieux
et elle présente encore une fois plus
souvent des affections de l'appareil
locomoteur donc des TMS
des allergies cutanées ou des élargies
respiratoires en lien avec les produits
et puis plus fréquemment aussi de la
souffrance psychique
la deuxième plaquette qu'on a publié
aussi récemment et qui va faire écho à
la première table ronde j'imagine de ce
matin c'est les professionnels de la
santé humaine et de l'action sociale et
là on retrouve clairement chez les
femmes et là une tendance vraiment
durable et historique plus de TMS
on voit que c'est un métier vraiment
très dur
notamment dans la santé humaine
également plus d'irritations et
d'allergie chez les femmes salariées en
santé humaine et puis une forte hausse
de la souffrance psychique on voit bien
avec les tensions de l'activité
notamment hospitalière
comme vous l'avez souligné on va sortir
des résultats avec une profondeur
historique de 2012-2018 le 18 avril donc
je manquerai pas de vous les faire
suivre et je finirai juste mon
intervention par deux points d'attention
c'est que souvent cette inégalité de
genre se double par une inégalité
sociale de santé puisque clairement pour
pour
à la fois pour les femmes et à domicile
la santé humaine et l'action sociale et
aussi la grande distribution alimentaire
ce sont les femmes ouvrières ou
employées qui sont plus impactés que les
professions intellectuelles ou cadres
évidemment ça se comprend par le métier
quel qu'elles font mais il y a un vrai
gradient social doublé de ce de cette
inégalité de genre et un point important
puisque ce programme est le seul
programme en France qui permet de
mesurer de quantifier la
sous-déclaration
pour vous donner un chiffre qui est
assez constant c'est environ 75% des TMS
qui correspondent à un tableau de
maladie de professionnels existants donc
il pourrait faire l'objet d'une
déclaration
une réparation donc ne font pas l'objet
d'une déclaration donc c'est un chiffre
vraiment très important et les les
raisons qui sont souvent invoquées c'est
que souvent le salarié ne connaît pas le
dispositif de réparation il peut y avoir
un refus du salarié pour des raisons qui
sont par exemple de conserver son emploi
et donc de pas déclarer la maladie
professionnelle ou pour remplir les
conditions du tableau de maladie
professionnelle par exemple s'il manque
une radio ou il manque un examen médical
voilà les critères ne sont pas
satisfaits et il n'y a pas de réparation
merci de votre attention merci beaucoup
monsieur donc le deuxième intervenant de
cette table ronde et Monsieur
François-Xavier déveter professeur des
universités à Lille et auteur d'un
ouvrage consacré au métier de la propre
thé à vous cher Monsieur j'espère ne pas
avoir écorché votre nom non non tout est
parfait j'en profite juste pour dire
pour un changement de statut où je suis
également faire fort à ce nombre de
l'IRES l'institut de recherche
économique et sociale voilà
à qui de droit c'est truc mais c'est
tout récent alors effectivement moi je
vais vous parler de des métiers de la de
la propreté plus spécifiquement du
secteur de la propreté avec peut-être un
point de préambule sur l'organisation
justement de ces métiers qui sont un peu
découpés en deux gros paquets on
pourrait même faire plus de division si
on le si on le souhaitait mais entre
ceux qui sont qui relèvent des
prestataires de services les entreprises
de la branche et puis les salariés qui
s'occupent de des questions d'entretien
de nettoyage de pauvreté mais au sein
d'une entreprise d'une administration
éventuellement qui ne relève pas de la
branche de la propreté voilà c'est deux
paquets importants de salariés
connaissent des conditions de travail et
des conditions derrière de santé qui
peuvent être assez différentes je vais
pas avoir le temps de rentrer à chaque
fois dans le détail de la différence
mais on y reviendra éventuellement sur
sur les questions alors sur le cœur de
mon intervention elle se déroulera en
quatre points je commencerai par une
deux brèves illustrations anecdotes en
quelque sorte mais qui ont une valeur
probablement qui va au-delà de la
dimension anecdotique ensuite je point
très quelques chiffres ou quelques
données statistiques qui rejoindront
largement peut-être de manière un tout
petit peu moins précise mais qui
rejoindront ce qu'a dit Monsieur
bollongé avant je m'arrêterai ensuite un
instant sur les raisons qui expliquent
selon moi et selon mes collègues qui
avons mené ses recherches pourquoi on en
est dans cette situation là et je
terminerai par quelques pistes
éventuellement de réflexion alors les
deux premières le premier point c'est
deux anecdotes la première et la
suivante ça renvoie un échange sur les
réseaux sociaux entre Philippe Jouanny
président de la Fédération des
entreprises de propreté et Alexandre
Belletti chef d'entreprise de ce même
secteur Alexandre mediti en poste un
court message sur ces réseaux en disant
je le cite dans la propreté la
pénibilité est forte dans l'hôtellerie
la pénibilité est très forte
le premier donc Philippe Jouanny lui
répond dans très très rapidement dans la
propreté la pénibilité forte depuis
quand vous avez une stats je suis
preneur suit un smiley interrogatif face
à cette position très forte de son
collègue monsieur bellitty renvoie alors
aux publications de la DARES du
ministère du Travail
ce à quoi Monsieur Joigny lui répond que
ces statistiques sont contestés par la
Fédération des Entreprises de la
propreté et que je cite par ailleurs il
n'y a pas de notion de pénibilité
inscrite dans la nomenclature actuelle
des métiers référencés comme pénible cet
échange nous rappelle combien la
pénibilité est une question de
convention sociale de discussions et une
question aussi sociopolitique au-delà
d'un strict d'une strict observation je
retiens de ce qui était présenté juste
avant que peut-être que l'on pourrait
considérer des métiers à caractère
pénible et non pas directement pénible
au sens juridique du terme la deuxième
anecdote et celle de ou le deuxième
histoire est celle de Badia agent
d'entretien 50 ans depuis 20 ans elle
travaille elle travaille le matin de
6h30 à 9h dans pour la saucisse pour une
société et de 14h30 à 20h pour une autre
société au 31 décembre de l'année
dernière le chantier de la société de la
première celle du matin et repris par la
société de l'après-midi un premier
problème apparaît son temps de travail
cumulé dépasse le temps plein
l'entrepreneur ne l'entreprise ne veut
donc pas reprendre intégralement son
contrat des pressions des difficultés
elle finit par abandonner une partie de
ses heures de travail le problème majeur
pour nous n'est pas là le second
problème survient quelques jours plus
tard le 5 janvier elle est victime d'un
président du travail
aujourd'hui trois mois après elle n'est
toujours indemnisée que sur la base de
son premier contrat de travail où le
seul contrat travail savoir de deux
heures trente par semaine elle est
depuis trois mois à 400 euros par mois
alors qu'elle occupait normalement un
temps plein la prise en charge des
accidents du travail par l'assurance
maladie dans ce secteur est rendu
particulièrement complexe par
l'organisation économique de de du
travail et notamment par la
sous-traitance alors ces deux histoires
on peut les compléter par des
statistiques nombreuses on l'a évoqué
précédemment c'est comme pour la grande
distribution une difficulté à dénombrer
le nombre de salariés selon les sources
vous serez en de 300 000 à quasiment 800
000 est-ce qu'on compte des postes c'est
ce qu'on compte des personnes est-ce
qu'on compte des temps plein est-ce
qu'on compte des salariés qui sont là
tout au long de l'année est-ce qu'on
compte des contrats courts donc ça
renvoie une précarité forte qui
est un défi y compris aux analystes
statistiques c'est au moins deux tiers
si ce n'est plus de femmes c'est environ
40% d'immigrés là aussi avec des comptes
difficiles et une forte concentration de
ceci en Île-de-France c'est une moyenne
d'âge vous l'avez rappelé qui était levé
plus de 49 ans soit au moins 8 ans de
plus que la moyenne des actifs toutes
les enquêtes statistiques celles
notamment de la DARES sur les conditions
de travail ou de l'enquête sumère
également renvoie à un état de santé
déclaré mauvais des inaptitudes
fréquentes selon l'Enquête Emploi entre
60 et 62 ans ce sont 50% des salariés ou
anciens salariés de la propreté qui
déclare des limitations pour effectuer
les gestes de la vie quotidienne contre
un peu moins de 30% pour l'ensemble de
la population active les licenciements
pour inaptitude sont fréquents voire
très fréquents les nettoyeurs
représentent à eux seuls environ 7% des
licenciements pour inaptitude alors
qu'il ne représentent dans la même base
de données que 1,7 à 1,8% des CDI donc
c'est à peu près x 4
cette situation s'explique évidemment
par une exposition à de multiples
mauvaises conditions de travail on a
parlé de polyexposition tout à l'heure
on retrouve exactement la même chose
96% déclare des postures debout
prolongées plus des deux tiers des
mouvements douloureux pas sur pénibles
etc on peut aligner ici les chiffres qui
sont bien connus le risque chimique est
également très présent mal mesuré mais
par contre les études épidémiologiques
montrent des problèmes respiratoires et
dermatologiques largement sur
représentés dans ces populations sachant
que la plupart des études
épidémiologiques en la matière sont des
études plutôt internationales que dans
le cadre français mais sur cette
question je pense que ma collègue
reviendra de manière bien plus précise
et pertinente que moi les difficultés
sont également d'ordre temporels les des
journées hachées une densité de la
journée de travail qui est faible juste
un chiffre à nouveau si on rapporte le
temps de travail payé à l'amplitude de
la journée de travail donc le nombre
d'heures rémunéré au cours d'une journée
par rapport au nombre d'heures qui vont
entre le début de la journée et la fin
de la journée on est aux alentours de
60% vous avez parlé des aides à domicile
près préalablement j'imagine dans la
première session on retrouve la même
chose on est à peu près sur le même taux
on a une journée pour eux 60% à peu près
de la journée de travail en terme de en
tant que enfin calculer comme entre le
début et la fin de cette journée ne sont
payées donc on a une sous rémunération
quelque sorte de temps dédié au travail
qui ne sont pas au sens strict des temps
de travail les horaires sont atypiques
mais sont dans leur immense majorité non
dérogatoire de la même manière que
la définition des maladies la définition
la pénibilité fait l'objet de définition
juridique la nuit également et ben là
ici on a des salariés qui travaillent en
horaire décalés en horaire pénible pour
la vie familiale et la santé mais pas
entre minuit et 5h du matin c'est à dire
qu'elle ne travaille pas de nuit et non
pas les consommer les compensations
adéquates les difficultés psychosociales
sont également nombreuses un isolement
c'est sur le point sur lequel
j'insisterai qui est extrêmement marquée
et
un management le plus souvent assez
marqué par par la discipline
[Musique]
un dernier risque lié à la santé qui a
un impact important sur la santé c'est
le risque de pauvreté on est sur des
rémunérations horaires faibles on peut
prêt au niveau du SMIC un temps de
travail qui est à temps partiel résultat
on a selon les sources entre un tiers et
la moitié des salariés qui sont des
travailleurs pauvres et elles l'ensemble
des travailleurs de la pauvreté
constituent un le paquet le plus
important de ces travailleurs pauvres
troisième point de mon intervention plus
bref à quel pourquoi on est-on arrivé là
j'insisterai sur un point qui joue un
rôle particulièrement négatif pour les
pour les salariés concernés c'est le
fait qu'elle soit rejetée le plus
souvent hors de la commune dotée de
travail du site sur lequel elles
interviennent c'est à dire qu'elles sont
déléguées voire relégués à des
prestataires spécialisés qui dit
prestataire dit une faible marge de
manoeuvre et l'obligation de faire
pression pour les salariés pour
retrouver ces marges financière juste
une illustration à nouveau prenez un
bâtiment 2006 22h30 en 2006 22h30 de
nettoyage quotidien pour entretenir ce
bâtiment aujourd'hui 2023 12h30 de
nettoyage quotidien c'est une règle
assez courantes voilà on a par le
renouvellement des marchés une
diminution du volume de travail qui est
accordé pour des bâtiments qui sauf
vérification non pas tendance à se
réduire avec le temps c'est juste un
doublement des cadences qui est
évidemment pénible pour les pour les
salariés qui dit spécialisés dit
également une absence de diversité des
métiers et des tâches l'impossibilité de
reclassement lorsque l'on a des TMS
c'est le licenciement pour une aptitude
souvent qui s'impose c'est aussi du coup
la peur pour les salariés d'aller voir
la médecine du travail comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure la médecine du
travail est pas perçue comme un soutien
et perçu plutôt comme une autorisation à
travailler c'est à dire plus comme un
outil de contrôle que d'accompagnement
évidemment c'est d'une manière un peu
tranchée il faudrait plus nuancé à cette
branche on peut ajouter le fait que son
fonctionnement via l'article 7 qui
organise les transferts conventionnels
fait disparaître la notion d'employeur
et fait disparaître la responsabilité de
l'employeur y compris en termes de santé
dernier point ce sera mon mot de
conclusion
quelle évolution quelque sorte percevoir
ou envisagé
j'en dégagerai trois on a un enjeu
essentiel sur les rémunérations et qui
dit rémunération dit dans ce secteur
comme dans l'aide à domicile une
question de temps de travail je le dirai
de manière très simpliste quand on
nettoie à 28 heures semaine on est à
temps plein en termes d'usure
professionnelle donc les calculs ici du
temps qui devrait probablement être
modifié le deuxième élément ce sont les
conditions de travail au sens propre et
ici l'enjeu principal à mon sens mais il
y en a évidemment d'autres c'est l'enjeu
des cadences or les cadences sont d'une
opacité totale aujourd'hui alors
qu'elles sont pour le coup relativement
objectivable au-delà de 300 mètres
carrés à l'heure on est dans un travail
qui n'est pas soutenable troisième point
c'est l'exclusion l'invisilisation des
salariés elle pourrait le plus souvent
être intégré dans la communauté de
travail couverte par la Convention c'est
que santé sécurité au travail du donneur
d'ordre elle pourrait le plus souvent
travailler en journée elle pourrait
également se voir appliquer la
convention collective du donneur d'ordre
comme ça se fait par exemple dans
l'intérim qui n'est pas un secteur
particulièrement bien protégé pour
autant c'est transformations concernent
donc les employeurs mais concernent
également les donneurs d'ordre les
pouvoirs publics à ce titre représentent
environ un tiers du chiffre d'affaires
du secteur on a une circulaire de mars
2022 sur l'achat publique responsable
qui est une avancée assurément mais qui
reste peu appliquée et avec peu
d'éléments
concrets derrière pourtant pour une
grosse partie des salariés ou pour au
moins cette partie là des salariés les
pouvoirs publics sont en tant que
donneur d'ordre et régulateurs les
détenteurs de l'intégralité des leviers
pour changer la situation de ces
travailleurs je vous remercie de votre
attention et j'espère ne pas avoir trop
explosé merci Monsieur donc troisième
intervenante ce matin madame anithebo
money sociologue de la santé et
spécialiste des sujets de santé au
travail co-auteur d'un rapport sur
l'identification et la prévention des
expositions au cancer au gène dans les
produits de nettoyage et qui a également
travaillé sur les conditions de travail
des femmes en grande surface vous êtes
accompagné par
Marie-Christine Liman ancienne
infirmière du travail et membre comme
vous du gyscope 84 qui travaille sur les
cancers d'origine professionnelle je
vais vous laisser la parole et j'espère
je n'ai pas oublié un titre à votre
présentation ça va très bien merci
beaucoup
donc je
vais vous parler de l'invisibilisation
du travail des travailleuses et des mots
du travail dans ces activités de
nettoyage en prenant vraiment le relais
par rapport à ce que vient de nous
exposer
d'accord
ça va comme ça
donc
jusque je regarde comment ça marche
non je sais pas faire marcher ça faut
appuyer sur quoi
non c'est pas gagné
merci
donc très brièvement le plan de ce que
je vais présenter
un travail invisible des risques ignorés
à partir de des données de la DARES la
démarche de recherche DJ scopes
pour justement tenter de briser cette
invisibilité des cancers professionnels
avec une expertise des parcours
professionnels pour
identifier les expositions à des
cancérogènes avérés et puis je viendrai
sur les inégalités de genre et la
question du nettoyage
voilà un travail invisible
en fait c'est un travail sous-traité
comme la dit François-Xavier de Water
un travail sous-traité
ou un travail invisible du point de vue
de la fonction de nettoyage dans des
entreprises
pour tout ce qui est
travail sous-traité c'est à contrario
des rythmes et on l'a bien vu avec ce
que ce qui vient d'être présenté et puis
travail précaire à temps partiel et
c'est un travail éminemment confié aux
femmes la division du travail fait que
c'est majoritairement les femmes qui
sont concernées des risques l'ignorés en
fait la DARES a un ensemble d'enquêtes
qui permet quand même de pointer le
risque chimique en particulier je vais
m'arrêter sur celui là et dans les
métiers du nettoyage c'est au moins 61%
mais je dirais que c'est au moins parce
que là il y a une invisibilité sur
laquelle d'ailleurs nous travaillons
donc les groupes en intérêts
scientifiques sur les cancers d'origine
professionnelle c'est une en fait un
groupement d'intérêt scientifiques
réunis un certain nombre d'institutions
c'est celle qui était sur la diapositive
initiale qui
se mettent ensemble pour soutenir
institutionnellement scientifiquement et
financièrement un programme de recherche
sur quelque chose qui ne fait pas du
tout partie des thématiques
officielles je dirais de la recherche
scientifique donc depuis 2002
officiellement en Seine-Saint-Denis
ce programme existe et sous la forme
d'une enquête permanente auprès de
patients atteints de cancer alors pour
la Seine-Saint-Denis c'est les cancers
respiratoires et les cancérigénaires
nous travaillons avec des services
hospitaliers et nous faisons la
reconstitution des parcours
professionnels systématiquement de tous
qui sont atteints de cancer primitif
dans ces services
donc au fil du temps c'est 1200 patients
entre 2002 et 2023 pour lesquels nous
avons des réconstitutions de parcours
professionnel le giscotte 84 c'est
depuis 2017 et c'est plutôt les cancers
et les cancers hématologiques nous
travaillons avec le
CHR le centre hospitalier d'Avignon et
le service hospitalier sur les
hémopathies
cancéreuses donc cette démarche elle est
partie du constat d'une triple
invisibilité des cancers professionnels
l'ignorance toxique malheureusement il y
a énormément de substances qui sont
mises en milieu de travail et en
production sans avoir été testé pour la
toxicité
on évaluait dans les années début des
années 2000 à moins de 10 % le nombre de
substances qui sont évaluées en
comprenant y compris les les mélanges je
dirais
et cette ignorance toxique elle est plus
forte pour les uns les femmes que pour
les hommes et je viendrai un peu sur les
raisons de cette
ignorance toxique pour les femmes
l'invisibilité physique c'est que la
plupart des cancers ogènes ne sont pas
perceptibles pour les ceux qui les
manipulent les respires une fibre
d'amiante ne se voit pas
le benzène est totalement
inodore et de nombreuses substances
toxiques n'ont aucune les rayonnements
ne se perçoivent pas donc l'invisibilité
physique
joue pour maintenir dans l'ignorance les
travailleurs et j'aurais de multiples
exemples mais je vais pas prendre de
temps pour ça et l'invisibilité sociale
c'est le fait que il n'y a pas de
véritable traçabilité des expositions en
milieu de travail
on ne connaît pas
les expositions et il y a une
invisibilité sociale évidemment par
l'importance sous déclaration
des cancers professionnels mais aussi
d'autres maladies professionnelles qui
pourraient alerter sur justement le
risque de cancer alors dans nos enquêtes
le cancer était appréhendé comme un
événement Sentinel pour chaque patient
on considère que la maladie permet
d'accéder en rétrospectif aux
expositions professionnelles qu'il a
subi au cancérogène avérée donc par
rapport à une liste de cancérogènes
donc il y a un premier temps qui est la
réconcitution du parcours professionnel
un deuxième temps qui est l'expertise de
ces parcours professionnels par des
collectifs d'experts qui ont
l'expérience des conditions de travail
de la toxicologie de l'ergotoxygologie
enfin c'est ce sont des collectifs très
pluridisciplinaires qui permettent
d'identifier les cancérogènes et les
résultats que je vais vous donner sont
donc
le résultat de cette expertise et puis
il y a une phase prospective qui est que
ces collectivités d'experts se
prononcent sur la possibilité ou non de
faire une déclaration de maladies
professionnelles pour le patient et
ensuite il y a un suivi de la
reconnaissance pour analyser les
les obstacles au sein même du processus
de déclaration reconnaissance donc c'est
une recherche action avec ce que je
viens d'évoquer
du point de vue un peu structurel les
grandes
tendances que nous retrouvons dans ces
deux enquêtes qui concernent maintenant
environ 1600 patients au total c'est que
on est massivement sur avec des patients
dont les parcours sont marqués par la
précarisation sociale de l'emploi du
travail et de la santé
ce qui montre que les risques
d'exposition à des cancérogènes sont
massivement sur ces publics
une fréquence du travail ouvrier
sous-traitée avec les fonctions
maintenance nettoyage gestion des
déchets une fréquence de l'exposition
cancérogène dans l'activité de travail
dans nos enquêtes nous avons plus de 85%
des patients de ces services qui ont été
exposés et massivement exposés à des
cancérogènes avec une prédominance de la
polyexposition c'est à dire c'est pas un
cancérogène c'est jusqu'à 10 15
cancérogènes au cours d'un parcours
professionnel
alors j'ai
choisi de focaliser les les résultats
sur ce qui se passe en
dans le Vaucluse parce que
c'est les résultats les plus récents que
nous ayons et on a des résultats
par
sexe qui permettent de voir justement
comment se construit l'invisibilisation
des cancers professionnels chez les
femmes donc très rapidement les parcours
les patients inclus et tous les patients
dans la file active du service
les parcours c'est ce qu'on a pu
expertiser c'est-à-dire 318 sur 555 le
l'écart est lié souvent à la gravité de
la maladie qui rend impossible
l'entretien avec le malade
donc 188 hommes et 130 femmes ce qui
veut dire un extracieux de 1,5 environ
là dessus vous on a 85% d'exposer
moins que ça chez les femmes on n'a pas
mis le cette ligne là mais elle est
importante parce que c'est là où on voit
que chez les femmes il y a beaucoup
moins de connaissances
des risques toxiques parce que il y a
pratiquement
pas d'épidémiologie
je dirais qu'il y a une extrapolation de
l'épidémiologie sur les hommes vers les
femmes mais sur des métiers comme le
nettoyage par exemple il n'y a aucune
étude nettoyage
cancer
donc de ce fait là et là il y a des
études scientifiques qui ont été faites
en Canada au Canada en France pour
montrer qu'il y a un déficit énorme de
connaissances
épidémiologiques et toxicologique sur
les métiers féminins ensuite donc
à partir de la connaissance des
expositions
quelle orientation vers la déclaration
de maladies professionnelles on voit que
pour les hommes c'est 126 sur 188 et
pour les femmes 38 sur 130 donc déjà il
y a trois fois plus
en proportion d'hommes pour lesquels les
experts considèrent que la déclaration
de maladies professionnelles est
possible et
trois fois moins pour les femmes
ensuite l'engagement dans la déclaration
on voit que les femmes hésitent beaucoup
plus à s'engager malheureusement
et en reconnaissance on a encore un
déficit supplémentaire qui fait que le
sexe ratio arrive à
11,5 en termes de reconnaissance
en fait si on reprend
ce que ça signifie les hommes et les
femmes n'occupent pas les mêmes places
dans la division sociale du travail
c'est un peu tout ce que montre nos
trois présentations d'ailleurs il y a
une invisibilité des risques
cancérogènes et une invisibilité des
cancers professionnels il y a un énorme
angle mort qui est le nettoyage pour
lesquels là pour le coup on est presque
à 90%
sur une population féminine donc c'est
ce qui a motivé la création du groupe de
travail nettoyage
au gyscope 84 avec des experts et des
membres de l'équipe pour rechercher les
expositions cancérogènes c'est à dire
faire une veille documentaire analyse de
produits et puis revenir sur la
connaissance des parcours travail et
d'exposition pour essayer de
briser le mort
sur les substances je dirais que la
première démarche qui a été faite
sur 18 mois 2 ans
montre la présence de ces
sept cancérogènes qui sont pas des
cancérogènes exceptionnels le
formaldéhyde c'est un des produits les
plus utilisés dans le nettoyage et il a
été interdit en 2013 mais remplacé par
des produits qui sont qui
contiennent des libérateurs de de
formaldéhymes donc ça veut dire que même
si l'exposition a beaucoup diminué elle
reste présente or incancérogène c'est
une substance avec absence de seuil de
toxicité donc le format est là et dans
des situations de
polyexposition évidemment la présence du
formaldéhyde
certainement un rôle dans la possibilité
de
des cancers ensuite alors je vais pas
tous les détailler je voudrais
m'attarder sur deux autres la silice qui
est très présente dans l'Ajax le CIF et
un certain nombre de d'autres produits
pour lesquels il y aurait d'ailleurs là
aussi des
substituts possibles
la silice et sur le tableau 25 et c'est
un des polluants les plus connus depuis
peut-être deux siècles
et puis l'oxyde d'éthylène l'oxyde des
thylène est utilisée dans la
stérilisation beaucoup en milieu
hospitalier mais aussi dans des dans
d'autres milieux et je pense à une
entreprise d'Annonay qui a stérilisé
pendant des années et le nettoyage était
évidemment concerné par la pollution
extensive dans cette entreprise par
exemple je prends cet exemple
une entreprise qui s'appelle
tetramédical
ou le nettoyage était fait dans des
lieux où étaient entreposés les objets
stérilisés pour un dégazage en fait ça
s'appelle une
désorsion mais on a y compris chez les
personnels de nettoyage les femmes des
cancers et on va tenter évidemment de
les faire reconnaître en maladie
professionnelle donc rien que sur ces
trois cancérogènes on est sur une
situation très préoccupante du point de
vue de la l'exposition
ignorée des travailleuses et nettoyages
alors la connaissance des activités de
travail et d'exposition
il y a en plus les conditions réelles de
travail dans le nettoyage avec la
multiplicité des produits utilisés donc
des mélanges donc des effets de synergie
probable
l'utilisation de produits interdit dans
le ménage à domicile des activités de
travail exposantes c'est-à-dire des
postures et on a à travers la démarche
d'ergot toxicologie on sait que les
postures la respiration les contacts
cutanés vont accroître la possibilité
d'exposition et puis le travail en
milieu confiné et sur l'écho-exposition
et expositions successives c'est à dire
que en fait il y a bien sûr les produits
de nettoyage mais il y a aussi les
surfaces nettoyées et là je voulais
attirer l'attention sur l'amiante on a
une situation catastrophique du point de
vue de l'exposition des travailleuses du
nettoyage à l'amiante à travers les sols
amiantés qui s'appelle le dalami qu'on
trouve dans beaucoup de locaux publics y
compris des écoles des hôpitaux etc et
il y a une technique de nettoyage qui
s'appelle l'usage des monobrosses qui
fait que ça remet en suspension des
fibres d'amiante or dans ce cas là les
nettoyeuses devraient être équipés avec
les équipements
du utilisé dans tout ce qui est chantier
de désamiantage et malheureusement nous
n'avons pas obtenu jusqu'à présent
que la DGT se prononce là dessus il y a
une recommandation de lactable qui est
plus ou moins sur cet aspect là mais on
devrait avoir une interdiction des
monobrosses et je le dis fort parce que
je pense que si votre groupe de travail
votre commission peut s'exprimer
là-dessus ça nous aiderait nous au
niveau des chercheurs en santé publique
quand nous donnons ce type de
préconisation
en conclusion
nous notre démarche nos démarches
montrent une identité de problèmes qu'on
pourrait certainement décliner sur
toutes les régions de France
malheureusement donc il y a
urgence à briser l'invisibilité du rôle
du travail et de la division sociale et
sexuelle du travail dans l'épidémie de
cancer
il faut agir sur les causes du non
recours au droit à la réparation parce
que ça vraiment il y a une situation
très très préoccupante parce que les
femmes
ignorant les risques
sont beaucoup plus frileuses même quand
on leur on essaye de les convaincre
qu'il y a des risques elles sont
tellement convaincus qu'il y en a pas
parce que elles peuvent pas imaginer
qu'on les met dans une situation de
danger aussi grave que elles ne font pas
la démarche de déclaration même quand
elles y en aura et puis la prévention
est un domaine vierge jusqu'à présent
alors que s'il y a un domaine où la
substitution est possible c'est le
nettoyage on a ce que disait
Marie-Christine souvent il y a le savon
noir il y a tous les produits de
substitution non toxiques qui existent
et qui pourrait être vraiment utilisé il
y a cette interdiction aussi
du des monobross dans le nettoyage des
solinsés et malheureusement on en a
encore pour longtemps parce qu'il y en a
partout il y a eu 80 kilos d'Amiens de
par habitant importés en France et on en
a peut-être enlevé un dixième donc vous
voyez ce qui reste donc il y a un
problème d'information de formation et
il y a aussi la nécessité d'alerter les
acteurs de prévention c'est ce que nous
essayons de faire au travers des
institutions avec lesquelles qui sont
membres des deux vis
dont la DGT les
drets les inspecteurs du travail la
Carsat et les services de santé au
travail mais aussi
en premier lieu les CSE les
syndicalistes parce que sur les lieux de
travail et les syndicalisés donneurs
d'ordre c'est très important il faut que
ils aient cette information sur les
dangers
cancérogènes d'une nettoyage et puis il
y a quelque chose auquel je tiens
beaucoup c'est le droit au suivi pour
les personnes exposées au cancérigènes
mutagène toxiques pour la reproduction
en activité et le suivi post
professionnel et malheureusement c'est
suivi que ce soit en activité ou en post
professionnelle ne sont pas mis en
oeuvre voilà je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame pour cette présentation
extrêmement complète
donc je vais céder la parole à mesdames
les rapporteurs peut-être Marie-Pierre
Richer ou Laurence Rossignol
qui souhaite à réagir ou intervenir
Marie-Pierre
on va peut-être prendre toutes les
questions en même temps pour
vous n'avez pas forcément de questions
je pense que votre propriété extrêmement
précis et détaillée et vous allez nous
apporter des réponses à travers les
questionsnaires moi j'ai quand même été
assez assez étonné de voir ce que
contenu quand même de la communication
sur les entreprises de dans le domaine
de la propreté jamais personne ce soit
préoccupé de la santé des salariés c'est
quand même assez stupéfiant lorsqu'on on
voit tous les études qui sont menées sur
l'utilisation d'autres produits dans
d'autres secteurs et je pense notamment
à l'agriculture par exemple avec les
néonicotinoïdes donc c'est vraiment une
surprise et une découverte ce matin pour
moi de voir qu'il existe absolument rien
dans ce domaine alors qu'on sait très
bien que pour
nettoyer pour toutes ces entreprises de
nettoyage il y a de nombreux produits
utilisés avec des conséquences que vous
avez pu nous exposer Marie Pierre
Richard merci Madame la juste madame
Thébault money vous avez parlé des des
appareils monobross alors ça m'a
interpellé parce que il est vrai que
dans beaucoup de collectivités et
d'entreprises aujourd'hui pratiquement
tout le ménage est fait avec les
monobrosses je dirais aussi par
l'influence des commerciaux et enfin
c'est pas négligeable non plus les
entreprises commerciales et puis parce
que peut-être qu'au départ les personnes
qui font l'entretien ont vécu ça comme
un soulagement comme un apport je dis
pas que c'est le cas mais comme rendant
leur travail peut-être plus technique et
donc une certaine une certaine alors
valorisation entre guillemets de de ces
métiers moi je suis très étonnée je
découvre que ça ça fait remonter des
sols l'amiante et je dirais que ça
devrait nous interpeller oui que les
sols avec camion oui mais par le biais
des monobrosses ça remonte et vous avez
parlé notamment dans les écoles qu'il y
en avait beaucoup aussi de ces soldats
je suis quand même assez étonnée que ça
n'est pas plus interpellé alors quand
même des enfants enfin voilà on a
beaucoup de personnes qui fréquentent
nos écoles donc c'était par rapport par
rapport à la mono brosse et vous l'avez
évoqué très rapidement mais sinon peu
long évoqué les EPI on n'a pas parlé des
EPI est-ce que c'est justement par
rapport à la négligence du travail
effectué par ces femmes qu'on leur
propose pas des EPI est-ce que c'est
parce qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment de
formation pour expliquer en quoi ça peut
ça peut les prévenir de toutes ces
toutes ces maladies
vous avez parlé on a parlé de l'amiante
quand on regarde les métiers les métiers
dans le bâtiment on a vu que pour que la
reconnaissance de l'amiante notamment
pour les peintres en bâtiment etc soit
soit reconnu tous ces métiers là ça a
mis des décennies j'espère que ça n'en
mettra pas autant par rapport aux
produits qui sont aujourd'hui utilisés
et puis
monsieur boulanger tout à l'heure vous
nous avez parlé des études pardon
concernant
la baisse significative de la prévalence
des TMS
moi j'ai quand même j'aimerais avoir des
précisions parce que vous avez évoqué le
fait que c'était limité dans la mesure
elle avait aujourd'hui plus un rôle de
surveillance puisque on avait de plus en
plus de cases dites automatique mais
alors pour le coup je me dis dans ces
conditions-là on a aussi moins de de
femmes de salariés qui sont sur les
caisses
les caisses historiques on va dire et
pour le coup est-ce que ça contrarie pas
votre étude dans la mesure où si vous
avez moins de femmes qui sont dans ces
métiers répétitifs comment vous faites
la part des choses entre la baisse parce
qu'on le sait ça a eu des conséquences
quand même sur la baisse du recrutement
et puis vraiment l'impact
l'impact de ces caisses automatiques
c'est tout merci
Laurence oui
poser sont très clair et assez exhaustif
je retiens juste pour moi très
intéressant c'est qu'en fait il y a pas
d'épidémiologie c'est Madame Thébault
Monique il a évoqué tout à l'heure je
crois il y a pas d'épidémiologie sur les
substances chimiques utilisées dans les
métiers à dominants de féminine et on
travaille uniquement par extrapolation à
partir des métiers masculins et c'est
tellement
comparable à ce qui se passe de manière
générale en terme de santé voilà c'est
l'air trop la même chose en fait c'est
une espèce de permanence qu'il faudra à
mon sens noter dans notre dans notre
rapport c'est à dire que c'est moi
l'expression toute la santé publique la
santé enfin l'ocentrée quoi voilà donc
elle doit et on travaille que par
exemple je trouve ça assez intéressant à
vous à vrai dire pas penser et juste une
question peut-être c'est à la marge mais
quand même bien sûr les
cancérogènes sont celles dont on connaît
pas le niveau d'expérience dont on
connaît on n'a pas de seuil d'exposition
j'ai bien compris c'est on a voilà et
surtout toutes les substances du
nettoyage dont vous parlez est-ce qu'il
y a une étude qui est faite sur les
mères au foyer les femmes au foyer vous
savez les femmes qui nettoient toute la
journée à la maison
parce que ça concerne si ce n'est la
santé si ce n'est la santé
professionnelle des femmes ça concerne
aussi quand même la santé des femmes
voilà
merci beaucoup chers collègues peut-être
que les femmes ont foi lui ne nettoie
peut-être pas toute la journée quand
même
[Rires]
elles ont sûrement d'autres occupations
très intéressantes donc je vous laisse
vous organiser comme vous le souhaitez
pour répondre à nos collègues
rapporteurs
madame tes Bonnie ensuite monsieur
François-Xavier déveter et si monsieur
Guillaume boulanger souhaite compléter
il le fera merci
[Musique]
alors sur les sur les monomoros
en fait il y a un problème préalable qui
malheureusement là aussi pas
suffisamment évoqué c'est le problème de
l'évaluation des risques
et du repérage de l'amiante avant
travaux
le
diagnostic technique amiante
a été instaurée en 96 il devrait être à
disposition de toute personne qui veut
savoir ce qu'il y a
comme sol ou est-ce qu'il y a de
l'amiante dans le bâtiment parce que il
y a par exemple 85% des écoles pour
lesquelles on pense qu'elles sont encore
amiées
que ce soit quel que soit le niveau
d'enseignement donc le DTA devrait être
à disposition
et en fait ce DTA devrait conditionner
ensuite
toute démarche de travaux
quel qu'il soit y compris le nettoyage
bien sûr et donc quand on sait qu'il y a
du dalami quelque part il y a une
deuxième démarche qui est le repérage de
l'amiante avant travaux c'est quelque
chose qui a été introduit en 2012 et la
même chose pour le nettoyage c'est comme
si ça n'existait pas il y a un troisième
niveau c'est que
lorsqu'il y a une situation de
sous-traitance il doit y avoir un plan
de prévention établi entre le donneur
d'ordre et le sous-traitant le
sous-traitant est pas censé forcément
savoir que il travaille sur du dalami
c'est donc dans le cas du plan de
prévention que ça devrait être évoqué
avec quels sont les équipements de
protection nécessaires pour éviter
l'exposition à l'amiante ça c'est je
dirais l'architecture de la prévention
et ben demander à
une femme de ménage qui se retrouve dans
une école ou dans un hôpital où il y a
un où il y a du dalami et c'est mais
c'est du chinois pour elle elle sait
même pas que ça existe tout ça et c'est
même pas qu'il y a de la viande dans le
sol donc ensuite la question sur les EPI
moi je la dis la diviser en deux sur
l'amiante il est évident que pour ces ce
secteur là il devrait y avoir
équipement à partir du moment on utilise
des monoproses c'est tout si on veut
utiliser des monobrosses ce que je
trouve pas une bonne idée d'ailleurs
très franchement
à partir du moment où on sait qu'il y a
de l'amiante il faut pas les utiliser
c'est tout parce que là on met en
suspension un nuage de fibres absolument
invisible mais extrêmement nocif parce
qu'en plus elles sont fraîchement émises
donc elles sont encore plus réactives du
point de vue de leur toxicité donc
les les équipements devraient
automatiquement être mis à disposition
avec les conditions du port de l'équipe
1 c'est-à-dire que ces équipements sont
très fatigants il y a des dispositions
même sur le temps pendant lequel les
travailleurs portent cette équipement
la question des pose ensuite il y a la
question des vestiaires etc donc on
devrait être
dans le cas de figure d'un chantier
amianté c'est tout bon après il y a la
question des
EPI pour tout ce qui est les substances
toxiques que j'ai évoquées et là je vais
laisser Marie-Christine qui a beaucoup
loué l'expérience par rapport à ça
expliquer comment en fait
ça se passe dans la réalité pour les les
nettoyeuses et puis elle répondra aussi
sur les femmes de ménage les femmes au
foyer oui bonjour
pour ce qui est des EPI moi j'aimerais
qu'on remonte un peu en amont avec les
principes généraux de prévention du Code
du travail
les EPI ne devraient intervenir quand en
fin de liste
et d'abord il faudrait tout faire pour
la substitution c'est quand même le
principe le plus important on a notre
dispositions des produits non dangereux
ce serait quand même
dommage de continuer
d'utiliser des produits qui sont
allergisants irritants on l'a pas évoqué
et quand ces rejets mais ces produits
irritants et allergisants vont bombarder
vont agresser régulièrement le système
immunitaire et donc peuvent favoriser le
développement d'un cancer ces produits
irritants et allergisants dans les
produits de ménage ce sont des colorants
pour faire joli et des parfums pour
sentir bon
le savon noir ne présente pas ces
inconvénients le vinaigre blanc bon on a
l'air un peu et on chasse l'odeur le
bicarbonate de soude le nettoyage à la
vapeur tout ça ce sont des techniques
des procédés et des produits non
dangereux on s'est malheureusement fait
avoir depuis des décennies par les
fabricants de lessive qui ont voulu nous
vendre de belles choses mais
malheureusement et là je rejoins vous
dites les femmes au foyer et je dirais
plus largement les consommatrices nous
achetons en supermarché ou en droguerie
des produits donc on se dit c'est en
vente libre donc c'est pas dangereux
donc première représentation à combattre
ensuite il y a la question des
représentations
par exemple des personnes âgées qui vont
exiger de l'aide à domicile qu'elle
utilise de l'eau de javel alors que ça
leur est interdit parce que voilà les
gens âgés ont une représentation de la
javel produit miracle contre tous les
méchants microbes donc ça veut dire
former l'aide à domicile pour qu'elle
puisse argumenter auprès de la personne
âgée en disant non je n'ai pas le droit
d'utiliser l'eau de javel pour telle et
telle raison mais ça veut dire aussi que
le service d'aide à domicile va porter
ce message de prévention de
sensibilisation et d'informations aussi
directement auprès des bénéficiaires
lorsqu'ils se montrent très réticents de
manière à ce que l'aide à domicile ne
soit pas seul face à un bénéficiaire qui
lui a mis la bouteille d'eau de Javel
sous l'évier
les travailleurs les consommatrices les
femmes au foyer donc on est tous
confrontés à cette même difficulté et
quand on achète un produit en
supermarché et bien si on n'est pas
toxicologue on ne sait pas que le deux
Bromo 2 ni trop propane un 3e et
cancérigène
donc il y a l'étiquetage il y a la
lecture de l'étiquette des fois elle est
même pas lisible et puis il y a aussi
l'absence de la mention d'un produit
cancérigène parce que dans la
réglementation quelqu'un a décrété que
si c'était présent à moins de 5 %
on le notait pas sur l'étiquette alors
nouvelle fausse représentation parce que
ça laisse entendre que si c'est à 4%
c'est pas dangereux donc on les note pas
et si c'est a pour 6% c'est dangereux
alors on le note alors que ceci pour
cent 5% pardon ne repose sur aucune
donnée scientifique et que donc on nous
on a visibilité une information
importante sur un produit
potentiellement cancérogène donc on est
confronté à tout ce faisceau
d'invisibilisation qui fait que nous
sommes démunis et c'est une raison pour
lesquelles les femmes ne se sentent pas
légitimes à faire une démarche de
reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle
voilà j'ai utilisé du CIF en poudre j'ai
utilisé des berlingots de minimir ah
c'était pas dangereux et ben peut-être
bien que si donc on travaille sur les
compositions des produits disponibles
actuellement mais on a difficulté à
retrouver les informations sur la
composition des produits des années
80-90 2000 voilà
pour les ce qui est des EPI
encore faut-il qu'il soit fourni
adapté et porter
porter mais là encore ça renvoie à la
formation des aides des personnels de du
nettoyage ça renvoie
adapté au choix des des entreprises vous
pouvez avoir des gants qui sont
commandés seulement dans la grande
taille comme ça ça ira tout le monde bah
non quand vous avez une petite main le
gant il va pendouiller ça va vous
énerver il va tomber dans le seau et
vous allez pas le porter
vous avez des aides à domicile qui n'ont
pas accès aux boîtes de gants le
week-end parce que le week-end leur
siège social est fermé donc il peut
arriver que le samedi elsaillent
s'acheter elle-même une boîte de gants
en urgence en dépannage et puis adapté
On vous fournit des gants mais sont-ils
vraiment adaptés est-ce qu'ils sont
pauvres est-ce que le produit va passer
à travers le gant est-ce que Lyon est
trop court et le produit va se faufiler
entre le gant et la peau voilà c'est
toutes ces questions
la cadence aussi voilà est-ce qu'on peut
se changer
il y a plusieurs chantiers il y a
plusieurs bénéficiaires est-ce qu'on
peut se changer des pieds à la tête
quand on va quand on sort de chez
Monsieur Martin pour aller chez Madame
Dupont c'est toutes ces questions là qui
sont à travailler donc retenons bien le
grand principe de la substitution parce
qu'après on descend dans le détail et on
se retrouve confrontés à beaucoup de
problèmes la substitution c'est
important rappeler aux employeurs leurs
obligations ils ont obligation en
matière de santé et sécurité au travail
ils ont obligation de moyens et de
résultats or s'il y a des cancers c'est
que le résultat n'a pas été atteint
merci beaucoup pardon juste un point sur
les tableaux de maladies
professionnelles ils ont été pensés au
masculin les mines la chimie le bâtiment
travaux publics il faut penser
maintenant les tableaux de ma vie
professionnelle au féminin l'hôpital
la propreté etc etc merci beaucoup
madame Liman monsieur François-Xavier
déveter rapidement un mot d'abord pour
inciter sur ce que a dit Madame minimum
il faut rappeler aux employeurs leurs
obligations et pour ça il faut qu'il y
ait des employeurs pas uniquement sur le
plan formel mais qui soit présent et
c'est vrai que la sous-traitance fait
disparaître l'employeur et c'est vrai
que le particulier employeur On a j'ai
pas évoqué la partie domicile mais il y
aurait beaucoup à dire évidemment de ce
côté là également et là pour le coup le
système du particulier employeur est une
négation tout simplement de l'idée même
d'un employeur responsable le plus
souvent il n'y a pas de CHSCT derrière
il y a pas de CO derrière il y a pas de
collectif de travail il y a pas
d'accompagnement etc donc c'est
forcément des suivis à la fois médicaux
de sécurité etc qui sont qui sont plus
que plus que défaillant résultat très
souvent les choses sont renvoyées à la
responsabilité individuelle à la prise
de conscience de la salarié elle-même et
je pense que ça c'est un point sur
lequel on peut insister parce que ça
concerne à la fois les les EPI et la
façon dont on les met où on ne l'aimait
pas ça concerne également les formations
ou la prise de conscience que l'on a de
ce qui est dangereux de ce qui est ce
qui l'est pas et il est évident qu'il y
a la première étape c'est cette prise de
conscience individuelle sauf que
renvoyer au niveau individuel
semble un peu décalé dans le sens où on
sait très bien que cette prise de
conscience individuelle est extrêmement
dépendante du contexte organisationnel
dans lequel le travail s'effectue est
effectué c'est à dire qu'effectivement
on ne sait pas par soi-même on sait
parce qu'on a une formation on sait
parce qu'on a des collègues de travail
on sait parce qu'on a un accompagnement
un encadrement etc etc donc encore une
fois les situations de sous-traitance
d'emploi direct sont des situations qui
par nature par leur mode eux-mêmes ni
ces possibilités là je prendrai juste un
exemple très qui se décale un petit peu
mais quand même celui des assistantes
maternelles dont on a vous avez
peut-être parlé à d'autres moments et un
élément qui a qui est intéressant parce
que aussi ça montre les leviers
éventuels de transformation possible
vous dites que tout est pas perdu quoi
d'avance les assistantes maternelle en
2005 dans l'enquête condition de travail
déclare extrêmement majoritairement ne
pas porter de charge lourdes quand les
auxiliaires depuis l'agriculture portent
des charges lourdes comme moi je suis
économie j'en ai déduit que les enfants
gardaient à la crèche était beaucoup
plus lourd que les autres puis en fait
en 2013 et 2019 cet écart se réduit
considérablement c'est à dire que la
prise de conscience du fait qu'un enfant
on s'y merveilleux soit-il souper cette
lourd 15 16 20 kg même avant 3 ans est
venu progressivement le contexte de
travail a permis et l'accompagnement de
la Carsat des syndicats
des particuliers employeurs aussi sur ce
plan là ont permis de prendre conscience
d'une pénibilité qui n'était pas vécue
auparavant et sur les questions de
nettoyage et de produits chimiques
toxiques etc c'est également extrêmement
important
un dernier mois un point sur les EPI
c'est aussi un support de d'économie
pour les entreprises il y a pas de
petits profits en quelque sorte là
dessus donc c'est un une démarche sur
lequel on peut récupérer un petit peu
sur la mono brosse il y a un paradoxe on
voit très bien qu'elle est fortement
utilisée normalement la mono brosse dans
la classification de la branche c'est
automatiquement un passage en AS2 et les
AS2 statistiquement sont pas
majoritaires très très très très loin de
là c'est donc la l'usage et la
reconnaissance de son usage en fait est
très très décalé parce que ça a des
implications normalement en termes de
coûts qui ne qui devrait aussi être
répercuté sur les sur les deux en ordre
derrière
voilà juste du coup peut-être rappeler
un tout dernier point c'est que
un effet de de coût il y a des enjeux
économiques là derrière extrêmement
important mais on voit bien aussi à
travers tout ce que l'on a pu dire les
uns et les autres là qu'il y a des coûts
publics enfin qui sont reportés sur les
finances publiques de manière majeure
les coûts désinaptitudes le coup sur
l'assurance santé sur l'assurance
maladie etc qui ne sont pas intégrés
dans les calculs lorsque une décision
d'externalisation par exemple est faite
on oublie que au final c'est bien les
derrière la collectivité publique qui
récupérera la dépense merci madame Annie
Thibault monides souhaitait redire un
petit mot et après je vous laisse
conclure monsieur
juste pour dire par rapport à la
question des coûts que tous les cancers
professionnels qui ne sont pas reconnus
sont
portés au compte du régime général et de
l'assurance maladie
et pas à la charge des employeurs or il
y a moins de 0,5% de tous les cancers
qui sont reconnus en maladie
professionnelle précision intéressante
même si je vous ai contraint dans le
temps Madame à vous cher Monsieur
boulanger
alors peut-être plusieurs points alors
qui feront écho aux interventions
précédentes le code du travail organise
bien trois types de prévention la
prévention primaire donc sur lesquels
vous avez largement assisté à savoir la
substitution
ça concerne les produits chimiques mais
ça peut aussi concerner l'organisation
du travail effectivement les activités
d'entretien peuvent se faire la journée
et pas forcément la nuit de manière
finalement organisée pour moins
contraindre les travailleuses donc ça
c'est ça c'est possible
il y a aussi on voit bien que quand on
met en place justement
de nouvelles formes d'activités je pense
aux caissières aux employés de
libre-service il y a un impact qu'on
peut mesurer quantifier donc ça aussi
c'est un partage d'expérience qui est
qui à mon avis nécessaire à faire avec
d'autres secteurs vous avez cité aussi
les assistances en maternelle donc c'est
pour moi c'est important aussi de
pouvoir changer ou adapter les
conditions de travail donc ça c'est
vraiment la prévention primaire la
prévention secondaire c'est on ne peut
pas écarter le risque donc comment on
s'adapte et notamment la question des
des autres pays vous l'avez souligné il
faut qu'il soit adapté mais évidemment
par exemple en termes de type de
produits d'entretien on va pouvoir
utiliser dans certaines conditions du
savon noir mais à l'hôpital où là où il
y a une problématique avec des agents
infectieux qui sont plus réfractaires ou
plus dangereux là le savon noir va pas
suffire ok encore une fois c'est une
analyse d'aucun par cas qui doit se
faire sur la substitution le choix du
produit ou des conditions d'organisation
du travail et si on peut pas voilà on
met des EPI adaptés et encore une fois
il faut penser aussi parce que vous avez
ok aussi le le masque qui est utilisé
dans les chantiers de désamiantage qu'on
appelle un masque FFP3 donc une
protection très forte et qui contraint
beaucoup le travailleur dans son
activité donc attention quand on
préconise aussi de porter des masques si
vous faites une activité très physique
au bout d'un moment vous voulais pas
pouvoir maintenir le masque que vous
allez le retirer je crois qu'on a eu
toute cette expérience avec déjà des
masques chirurgicaux pendant la période
de confinement donc encore une fois
faire attention à bien adapter le risque
avec des moyens appropriés et la
prévention tertiaire c'est vraiment
accompagnée et notamment la réparation
et là encore une fois il faut
sensibiliser les personnes à la
possibilité de réparation on l'a bien vu
il y a une forte sous déclaration
de notamment qui concerne les TMS mais
les cancers encore plus
la souffrance psychique aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de tableau de maladie
professionnelle concernant la souffrance
psychique donc voilà sur chaque type de
prévention il y a un effort à faire et
notamment pour des secteurs où il y a
beaucoup de précarité très féminisés
donc c'est un effort important à faire
pour répondre plus particulièrement à
votre question
sur la le fait que finalement la prise
en charge de des pathologies et
finalement reporter sur la branche
générale il y a une commission qui
existe qui organisée à l'Assemblée à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui tous les 5
ans fait le bilan de la sous-déclaration
et qui demande à la branche assurance
maladie de reverser
de refaire de reverser à la branche
générale finalement l'équivalent et pour
vous dire c'est une somme considérable
puisque elle a été évaluée à un milliard
d'euros donc la branche ATMP de
l'Assurance Maladie reverse à la branche
générale 1 milliard d'euros par défaut
en fait de réparation des maladies à
caractère professionnel
oui ça change rien mais c'est pour dire
que il y a cette compensation qui est
faite et donc finalement il y a une
forme de visibilité mais ça change
effectivement de reconnaissance voilà de
la sous-décration
cette en termes de de d'épidémiologie je
voudrais insister sur ce point là parce
que à santé publique France on est les
premiers concernés il y a peu je l'ai
dit on introduction et vous avez
souligné ce point là il y a peu
d'épidémiologie c'est très difficile
pour pour les
le secteur de la surveillance sanitaire
les agences d'expertise comme santé
publique France ou le domaine de la
recherche de rentrer dans une entreprise
ça se fait sur la base du volontariat et
c'est très compliqué nous on a beaucoup
de difficultés à aller faire des études
épidémiologiques dans les entreprises
donc là c'est pareil c'est des
recommandations qu'on fait de de portage
institutionnels des administrations du
politique pour justement assurer cette
mission à la fois de de surveillance
épidémiologique par les agences
d'expertise et par la communauté de des
chercheurs
et pour répondre maintenant plus
particulièrement à votre question
effectivement on a vu que il y a de
moins en moins de postes de caissières
au fil du temps avec l'automatisation et
les caisses ont libres services
néanmoins d'un point de vue
épidémiologique et statistique on a des
effectifs qui restent conséquents on
travaille sur j'allais dire plus de
20.000 cas ce qui fait qu'on peut
comparer des effectifs qui étaient plus
importants en termes de caissière avant
avec des effectifs qui sont moins
importants en termes de caissières ça il
y a des méthodes statistiques qui nous
permettent de le faire et qui nous
permettent d'avoir des données j'allais
dire probantes et robuste donc on va
être finalement la diminution de
l'effectif nous contraint pas trop dans
la comparaison des analyses j'espère
avoir été clair et le dernier point pour
dire qu'on travaille avec le
l'Observatoire de la qualité de l'air
intérieur ça c'était plutôt pour Madame
rossignol qui mène une campagne de
mesure dans
600 log en France et qui a vocation à
être représentative de tous les
logements en France et nous on fait
passer un questionnaire santé justement
et un questionnaire d'utilisation des
produits de d'entretien et notre mission
notre objectif c'est de voir s'il y a un
lien justement entre les personnes du
foyer et l'utilisation de produits
d'entretien et notamment les personnes
qui restent à domicile toute la journée
donc ça c'est des résultats qui sont pas
publiés avant 2025 je pense mais voilà
qui est encore une fois
qui montre l'intérêt de la question qui
a été soulevée
merci merci beaucoup mesdames et
messieurs pour ces interventions ou
clôtures donc cette matinée consacrée au
métier du Caire au métier des GMS et de
la propreté avec des choses extrêmement
des informations extrêmement précieuses
que vous nous avez livré notamment sur
l'invisibilité sur les techniques sur la
reconnaissance et plutôt je dirais le
déficit de reconnaissance de maladies
professionnelles donc n'hésitez pas à
vous aviez reçu un questionnaire à nous
envoyer si vous le souhaitez des
éléments complémentaires des des
informations complémentaires qui
viendront étayer le rapport puisque
comme vous le voyez nous sommes dans des
conditions dégradées de réunion à cause
des mouvements
et des grèves dans les transports et que
ça complique un petit peu l'organisation
ces jours là au Sénat de réunion avec
une forte participation dessinateurs et
sénatrices donc excusez-nous pour ces
mais de toute façon nous avons des
comptes rendus qui sont très précis et
qui permettent à tous de se mettre à
niveau très rapidement madame s'il vous
plaît
finir sur une bonne nouvelle c'est un
sujet quand même dur les pays nordiques
se sont penchés sur le travail de nuit
au niveau du nettoyage à cause du risque
cancérigène et donc le travail a été
modifié transformé et désormais le
nettoyage se fait en journée et non plus
de nuit merci tout à fait et pour avoir
entendu parfois les entreprises et les
représentants des entreprises de
propreté c'est une piste qui me paraît
tout à fait une solution assez
pragmatique et qui devrait pouvoir se
mettre en oeuvre et dans des heures où
nous avons besoin de relation sociale
importante après une crise du covid je
pense que ce serait bénéfique pour tous
donc merci à vous pour cette
participation à cette deuxième table
ronde et excellente journée à tous et à
toutes et merci au rapporteur